.
GOOD EVENING, IT'S ONLY TAKEN
SEVEN DAYS BUT NOW ELON MUSK IS
SLASHING JOBS AT TWITTER AFTER
REPORTS BUT HE CUT HIS SEVEN
AND A HALF THOUSAND WORKFORCE
IN HALF.
AND THE METHOD THAT HAS BEEN
USED, BRUTAL.
THE DOORS WERE LOCKED AT THE
COMPANY'S OFFICES, ACCESS TO
INTERNAL SYSTEMS WERE CUT.
AND STAFF MEMBERS WERE INFORMED
VIA EMAIL, IF YOU GOTTEN A MAIL
TO YOU WORK EMAIL, YOU KEPT
YOUR JOB.
AND IF YOU GOT YOUR EMAIL TO
YOUR PERSONAL EMAIL, YOU ARE
OUT OF A JOB.
ALREADY HIT WITH A CLASS
ACTION.
ALLEGING THAT THE COMPANY HAS
VIOLATED LABOR LAWS, BY NOT
GIVING NOTICE IN THE CORRECT
WAY.
AS MUSK SHAKES UP TWITTER, THE
PROBLEM IS, HOW IT MAKES MONEY.
HE HAS TWEETED, TWITTER HAS HAD
A MASSIVE DROP IN REVENUE.
TWITTER AT TOUGHEST GROUPS
PRESSURING ADVERTISERS.
COVERING THIS IN ALL OF IT
MANIFESTATIONS, LET'S GO
THROUGH THE FIRING FIRST, FIRST
OF ALL, THE LOTTERY OF WHERE
YOU GOT YOUR EMAIL TOLD YOU
WHETHER YOU HAD BEEN FIRED.
>> ABSOLUTELY BRUTAL, I THINK
THIS EMAIL WENT OUT AT ABOUT
8:00 OR SO ON THE EAST COAST IN
THE U.S. LAST NIGHT.
THE EMAIL, NOT SIGNED BY ANYONE,
GOING TO ALL STAFF SAYING, IF
YOU GET AN EMAIL TO YOUR
PERSONAL EMAIL, YOU ARE GONE,
IF YOU GET AN EMAIL TO YOUR
WORK EMAIL THEN YOU ARE STILL
AT THE COMPANY.
I HAVE BEEN SPEAKING TO LOSS OF
WORKERS.
SOME OF THEM ARE KIND OF
RELIEVED.
THEY'RE SEEING THE DIRECTION
THAT THIS COMPANY IS GOING, AND
THEY'RE HAPPY TO GET OUT, BUT
OBVIOUSLY OTHERS ARE
DEVASTATED.
SOME PEOPLE ARE ON VISAS,
FOREIGN WORKERS HERE IN THE
U.S. WHO MAY NEED TO LEAVE THE
COUNTRY AND WHATNOT.
DEVASTATION THERE, RICHARD.
>> THE POINT IS, HE HAS ONLY
OWNED A COMPANY FOR SEVEN DAYS,
ONE COULD ARGUE AND MAKE A
BIBLICAL ANALOGY ABOUT HOW LONG
IT TOOK THE CREATOR TO MAKE THE
WORLD.
THAT IS ANOTHER ISSUE.
HE RESTED ON THE SEVENTH DAY,
AT LEAST.
ON THE SEVENTH DAY, HE FIRED
EVERYBODY.
BUT THE POINT IS, HOW COULD HE
KNOW WHO TO KEEP AND WHO TO LET
GO?
WHICH WAS THE GOOD AND WHICH
WAS THE BAD?
WITH ANY TEAM?
WHO WAS THE DROSS AND WHO WAS
THAT GOOD?
>> THERE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE ANY
RHYME TO IT, THAT'S THE VERY
QUESTION THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO WERE FIRED TODAY ARE
ASKING.
HOW DID THEY DECIDE TO FIRE ME?
WE KNOW THAT THEY JUST TOTALLY
ELIMINATED SOME TEAMS, THERE
WAS SOME TEENS, THERE WAS ONE
CALLED THE CURATION TEAM.
THEY WOULD HAVE HAD A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE NEXT WEEK WITH
THE ELECTION IN THE U.S..
WHEN THERE WERE VIRAL LIES,
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, OUT OF
NOWHERE, WE WILL SEE SO MUCH OF
THAT NEXT WEEK WITH THE
ELECTION.
THEY WOULD CURATE TWEETS, PUT
THE INFORMATION INTO CONTEXT
AND THAT WOULD BE BOOSTED OUT
TO THE TWITTER AUDIENCE TO TRY
TO PUSH BACK ON SOME OF THE
MISINFORMATION.
THAT TEAM IS COMPLETELY GONE.
>> THANK YOU, AS TWITTER
EMPLOYEES ARE LEARNING THE
FAITH THEMSELF, TWITTER WAS
CONFIRMING THE EXTENT OF THE
DRUG CUT.
>> TODAY WE FIRED HALF OF
TWITTER, AND THAT SHOULD SAVE
US FOUR BILLION A YEAR.
>> NO, IT'S NOT GOING TO SAVE
FOUR BILLION A YEAR.
I WISH.
TO BE FRANK, TWITTER WAS HAVING
A PRETTY SERIOUS REVENUE
CHALLENGE AND COST CHALLENGE,
BEFORE THE ACQUISITION TALKS
STARTED.
ANY COMPANY THAT IS DEPENDENT
ON ADVERTISING HAS HAD A HARD
TIME.
>> FRANCIS PHRASE, HIRED TO FIX
MOVERS BROKEN CULTURE IN 2017,
WE WILL GET TO THE UBER AND
WHAT YOU WROTE IN YOUR
FASCINATING ARTICLE IN THE
HARVARD BUSINESS REVIEW, BUT
GIVE ME YOUR GUT.
YOUR GUT FEELING TODAY WHEN YOU
HEARD WHAT HE HAD DONE.
>> I WAS NOT SURPRISED BUT
DISAPPOINTED, WHEN YOU DO
LAYOFFS YOU CAN DO IT IN A
TRUST BUILDING WAY OR A TRUST
DESTROYING WAY AND THIS WAS
ALMOST A SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE
SKIT OF HOW TO DO IT IN A
DESTROYING WAY.
WITH ALL THE HUMANS INVOLVED
IT'S SO DISAPPOINTING BECAUSE
IT WAS SO UNNECESSARY TO DO IT
IN THIS WAY.
>> ALLOWING FOR THE TRUST,
CRUCIAL, IT'S ALSO ARGUABLY THE
LEAST EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE
WAY, BECAUSE YOU COULD HAVE
THROWN THE BABY OUT WITH THE
BATHWATER.
>> YES, NOT ONLY DID HE NOT
KNOW, LET'S SAY THAT THERE WAS
SOME ECONOMIC REASON TO DO IT.
THE WAY IN WHICH HE CHOSE TO DO,
IT SHOWS EVERYONE WHO HE
AUTHENTICALLY IS.
SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T TAKE CARE,
DOESN'T ACKNOWLEDGE THE LOGIC,
HE BROUGHT IN A BILLION DOLLAR
OF DEBT, HE IS NOT TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE WAY IN
WHICH HE PURCHASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
HE MIGHT BE SHOWING HIS REAL
SELF, BUT THAT IS GOING TO MAKE
US ALL NOW VERY SUSPICIOUS OF
HIM.
AND HE NEEDED TO HAVE DONE
THAT.
>> WHAT ABOUT THOSE WHO FUNDED
THIS TRANSACTION BESIDES HIS
OWN WEALTH?
THE VENTURE CAPITALISTS, THE
HEDGE FUNDS, YOU
INSTITUTIONALIST?
THAT ALL WENT TO THE, BANK LENT
HIM MONEY, HOW MUST THEY BE
FEELING TODAY?
>> I HOPE THEY ARE FEELING THE
HUMANITY AND THE COST OF WHAT
IS GOING ON.
I HOPE THEY ARE NOT SIMPLY
LOOKING AT THE RETURN.
SOMETIMES THE PEOPLE IN THE
BACKGROUND OF THE FINANCING
DON'T, AREN'T HELD RESPONSIBLE
FOR WHAT HAPPENS.
AND IT'S JUST THE PEOPLE
UPFRONT.
BUT THIS, AGAIN, IS JUST A
REALLY UNFORTUNATE WAY TO DO
IT.
AND IT HAPPENS, IF YOU LOOK AT
THE LAYOFFS THAT WERE ANNOUNCED
TODAY HERE, AND WITH STRIPE,
STRIPE DID IT BEAUTIFULLY.
SO I THINK HE WILL SUFFER FROM
THE FACT THAT HE DID IT ON THE
SAME 24-HOUR PERIOD OF SOMEBODY
WHO DID IT IN A TRUST BUILDING
WAY.
>> YOU ADVISED UBER, I'M
READING FROM YOUR ARTICLE.
IT'S WELL WORTH LOOKING UP.
IN THE HARVARD BUSINESS REVIEW.
TRUST, YOU SAY IT AGAIN, COURT
DRIVERS OF TRUST.
THE TRUST TRIANGLE.
ON ONE LEVEL, I OWN IT,
THEREFORE I DO WHAT I WANT.
BUT CAN THERE BE ANY REBUILDING
OF TRUST HERE?
>> TODAY WOULD HAVE BEEN A
GREAT CHANCE FOR HIM TO HAVE
REBUILT THE TRUST HE LOST IN
THE FIRST SIX DAYS, SO THIS WAS
A GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
WITH EACH DAY THAT PASSES, WE
HAVE MORE AND MORE EVIDENCE TO
OVERCOME HIM SHOWING WHO HE
REALLY IS.
WHICH IS, SO FAR, IF YOU LOOK
AT THE DATA IT'S SOMEONE WHO
DOESN'T BROADLY CARE ABOUT THE
EMPLOYEES.
THE EMPLOYEES THAT LEFT, HOW
THE EMPLOYEES THAT STAYED CARE
ABOUT THE EMPLOYEES THAT LEFT.
WHAT I FEAR IS THAT HIS
AUTHENTICITY IS REALLY CLEAR.
HE COULD ONLY REBUILD TRUST IF
HE, FROM THIS DAY FORWARD,
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT HE DIDN'T
HAVE EMPATHY AND START TO HAVE
EMPATHY AND IMPROVE HIS LOGIC.
BUT THAT WOULD REQUIRE A
LEARNING MINDSET AND I'M NOT
SURE, ELON MUSK IS MANY THINGS
BUT I'M NOT SURE HE HAS A
LEARNING MINDSET.
>> FRANCES FREI IF HE CALLS YOU
UP AND SAYS, WHEN YOU TAKE ON
THE TASK, WHAT YOU DO?
IT >> HE WOULD HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ALL OF THE PROBLEMS
HE HAD, INCLUDING TODAY, AND HE
WOULD HAVE TO SAY I'M OPEN TO
CHANGING STARTING NOW, WILL YOU
HELP ME?
SHORT OF THAT, NOT A CHANCE.
>> THANK YOU FOR JOINING US, I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TONIGHT.
THE TECH GURU SHELLEY PALMER
HAS DESCRIBED TWITTERS FIRINGS
AS TWISTED.
WHERE YOU GOT YOUR EMAIL TOLD
YOU IF YOU HAD BEEN FIRED.
FIRING BY EMAIL IS CALLOUS AND
DESTRUCTIVE IN ITS OWN RIGHT,
SECONDLY BECAUSE ELON MUSK HAS
ONLY OWNED TWITTER FOR A WEEK.
HIS PEOPLE CANNOT KNOW WHO IS
GOOD, WHO IS NOT, WHO SHOULD BE
KEPT OR LET GO.
I CAN HARDLY IMAGINE THE
PREVIOUS MANAGEMENT PREPARING
THE NECESSARY DOSSIERS NEEDED
TO EXECUTE.
WHAT ABOUT THE BANKS AND
INVESTORS HOME FUNDED THIS?
WHAT THEY LIKE THEIR SONS AND
DAUGHTERS TO BE FIRED IN THIS
WAY?
IT WAS IN 1973 WHEN THE BRITISH
PRIME MINISTER EDWARD HEATH
DESCRIBED --
AS THE UNACCEPTABLE FACE OF
CAPITALISM.
HAVING SEEN HOW TWITTER'S NEW
OWNER CARRIED OUT TODA